who
actually owns the rights to hannibal
right now in terms of
if you guys magically could get money
together to do more
who needs to say yes who needs to sign
off martha delaurentis is
is it controls the rights for
the hannibal character and galmont who
produced
the hannibal television series that we
worked on
uh has the rights to those characters
and those situations so if we want to
continue
telling the tales that we were telling
galmont needs to be involved and martha
delaurentis needs to be involved and
then of course we need a network to want
to
to platform us i listen i put on twitter
that i was going to talk to you guys
and rather than go through the 500
versions of this
uh my one blanket question is is there
any sort of
update in terms of doing anything more
with you guys together with hannibal
um is it just one of these things that
we're just hope or just should be up
you know what i mean like can you share
anything and i think that sums up about
a thousand questions
i wish there was something that that was
definitive we've you know i've had
conversations with hugh and maz and
other members of the cast in terms of
like
well this is what we would do if we were
allowed to come back
and there's some you know ideas that i'm
very excited about
and things that that sort of continue
the strange trajectory of season three
but i i have not been approached even
though like i've
i've knocked on every door uh and rang
every bell
and martha and i you know every every
couple of years pick up our
our uh bags and and go door-to-door
and see if anybody's interested in
revisiting and and really like the
biggest hurdle is that
we were somebody else's show and so
what i love about like netflix uh
platforming the show now is that there's
an opportunity for it to be seen as a
netflix show and maybe that will recon
uh
figure their appetite so to speak
but it's nobody has said anything to me
officially and believe me
like you know the nickel hooker on uh
you know the red light district i am
hanging out the window
waving my legs uh do they know i'm ready
if netflix came to you and said we would
love to do like a two-hour movie
rather than another season is that
something that interests you or do you
think that the
price of doing a movie would almost be
like we should just do another season
i'd love to hear hugh's take on this i
just want to work with you
again so i would do whatever anybody
offered me in whatever capacity
i agree with brian and and i would defer
to brian's
sense of what what would work you know
if
the story that that that he wanted to
tell and where he imagined taking it
could work in that format i mean
obviously this is a
wildly hypothetical question but um
but yeah in in in the hypothetical
absolutely
i mean i'm in basically